[Musique]
moi je fais environ 70 vaccins par jour
sans compter les vaccins gates demande
très forte de vaccination
avec une augmentation notable du nombre
de personnes qui se font vacciner pour
la première fois c'est à dire les primo
vaccinant tout en ayant une demande très
soutenue pour la dose de rappel commune
mendient troisième dose
de l'ordre de 60% des vaccins réalisée
en ambulatoire sont faits par des
pharmaciens on a un petit problème
d'ajustement de nos doses par rapport à
la demande
puisque il y à une plateforme nationale
qui gère le nombre de flacons attribué à
chaque effecteur mais qui ont un délai
de livraison de dix jours et on voit
bien que depuis les annonces du ministre
on a une très très forte demande et donc
on va essayer de s'ajuster le plus
rapidement possible
[Musique]
on a besoin des deux circuits c'est à
dire la ville avec les médecins les
infirmiers les sages femmes des
chirurgiens dentistes et pharmaciens et
les biologistes qui ont cette activité
de vaccination et on a un deuxième
circuit qui est celui dit des centres de
vaccination qui ont l'air de vouloir se
remettre en place